meanwhile in new york city mayor bill de
blasio has been moving for years to stop
asians from getting into new york city's
elite high schools in fact
his plan was to basically shut down high
schools rather than allow there to be
elite high schools at which asian
americans were overrepresented
so active discrimination active
discrimination against asian americans
is a core part of the democratic
platform
that seems like anti-asian hate to me
frankly if you're saying that a person
can't get into school
because they are performing too well
because they don't have the right race
that is anti-asian discrimination that
is anti-asian hate
it's a lot more hateful frankly than
suggesting that a virus that came from
china is in fact a chinese virus
okay but according to the left racism
against asian americans is fine so long
as it comports with their agenda
and it is not fine when they are allowed
to use it as a brick bat with which to
club the united states more broadly
which is how you end up with pieces like
this one
from the root okay there's a guy named
damon young
it's an insane piece he wrote he wrote
this piece yesterday
whiteness is a pandemic quote
i don't have much to add here today that
hasn't already been said whiteness is a
public health crisis
whiteness remember this is not about
white supremacy
like in its classic definition anymore
this is not about white people believing
they are superior to other races
whiteness itself is a pandemic it
shortens life expectancies it pollutes
air it constricts equilibrium it
devastates force it melts ice caps it
sparks and funds wars it flattens
dialects it infests consciousnesses
and it kills people white people and
people who are not white my mom included
there will be people who die in 2050
because of white supremacy-induced
decisions from 1850
the whole system has to be torn down and
it doesn't matter whether you can
actually identify the white supremacy in
any particular incident
everything bad that happens on planet
earth is due to whiteness
all of it is due to whiteness because
whiteness is buried in the
superstructure
whiteness is at the root of the tree
that is the civilization
and so every bad fruit of that tree is
because the root itself is rotten
a lion cannon should be drawn from the
actions of the white supremacists who
walked into three atlanta area massage
parlors yesterday
and allegedly killed eight people six of
whom were of asian descent to the
relentless anti-asian rhetoric
pollinating national discourse
over the past year based on based on
what
damon young you gonna provide any
evidence of this the former president
and the party of the former president
canon should be blamed for this
and the sudden increase of racist
violence against asian americans the
line doesn't stop there it extends back
400 years and has tentacles clawing
everywhere white supremacist
white supremacy exists here in america
which is everywhere
there's a line connecting this act of
terror to the 11 people killed at the
tree of life synagogue in 2018
the nine people killed at the emanuel
african methodist episcopal church in
2015 of course
well first of all you'd have to show the
evidence of that those were actual
overtly white supremacist acts of
terrorism
we don't know the answer on this one it
may be but we don't know that yet
in fact there was a tweet yesterday that
was that was particularly illuminating
i believe it was from ibram kendy and
his suggestion was
that it does not matter i'm sorry not it
was not emotion kenny
it was michael harriet who also writes
for the root he tweeted quote there will
never be any data that says racial
violence is because of white supremacy
because most white supremacists don't
think they are white supremacists
so in other words we don't actually have
to prove white supremacy at any point
we don't even have to listen to the
motivations of people who are who are
who are committing these acts
all we have to do is just attribute
white supremacy to them because they
don't know their own minds that is
complete unfalsifiable nonsense
just absolutely unfalsifiable nonsense
but that of course is the point
so back to this piece from this writer
damon young
at the root i just have to read you the
end of this piece
white supremacy is a virus that like
other viruses will not die until there
are no bodies left for it to infect
which means the only way to stop it is
to locate it isolate it extract it and
kill it
i guess a vaccine could work too but
we've had 400 years to develop one
so i won't hold my breath i don't even
know what the hell that is supposed to
mean this is a contributing opinion
writer for the new york times
i do not understand what that is
supposed to mean there are no more
bodies left
i mean are you talking about killing
white people like what ex i honestly got
i don't know what that means maybe it
doesn't mean that but
i read to you verbatim that paragraph i
don't know what it means here is what i
do know
what i do know is that the left does not
give two dams about anti-asian
discrimination
and education they don't care about
anti-asian discrimination
in the workplace they don't care about
anti-discrimination in virtually every
area of life where asians are considered
part of the broad white majority because
they are quote unquote too successful
they don't care about asians who are
beat up by particular members of
particular races
they only care about anti-asian hate
when it becomes a convenient point
for them to try and plant the notion
that america is
is a white supremacist country by the
way if america is such a terribly white
supremacist country
one indicator is not a particular white
overall would be that the single
greatest economically performing
subgroup in america are asian americans
okay so none of this makes any sense but
again it doesn't have to make sense
any any club that can be wielded against
the foundational
ideas of america the meritocracy the
the freedoms of america any idea that
can be wielded against that any incident
without evidence that can be wielded
against that
that can be attributed to quote-unquote
whiteness and whiteness means all the
institutions
according to the left not according to
me i'm not a racist so i don't think
that our institutions are quote unquote
white
i don't think that freedom is a white
idea i don't think that it's a
i think freedom is a civilized idea i
don't think individual rights are a
white idea
okay only the left thinks that crap but
what the left is trying to do as
always is have it both ways they always
want it both ways there's only one
there's one set of rules that applies to
people who are
higher ranking on the intersectional
hierarchy who get apparently to
victimize asian americans whenever they
want
and then there is a second set of rules
that applies to a society that is not
even responsible for
this particular act or for an
independent white supremacist movement
an actual white supremacist movement
that commits acts of evil at every
available turn
again it's the same way they treat
anti-semitism the way they treat
anti-semitism is it only exists
if you can try to plant it on the right
meanwhile we will back
every antisemite we can find in congress
as long as they have a d next to their
name
that's the way this works it's cynical
and it's gross and it does not fight
hate and it does not mitigate against
hate
if we're not fighting all hate the same
way then you're not actually fighting
hate are you
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content